[Music]
all of us are
Racers so deadly
passion our terrible Joy no wonder we
need me back how can I stay
wave if analy is looking for a
scapegoat then he I tell us why was Enzo
Ferrari a character you wanted to spend
some time with
Sydney poock Troy Katy Martin and I
started this in
1994 and um the the fortuitous accident
that all there was this kind of fractal
of these four months that happened in
1957 and all the the Opera the drama the
tumultuous passion of romances and
everything going around the tragedy the
death of Dino your young son yearning
for his father Pi the Collision of all
these uh kind of became the
quintessential uh story of Enzo
everything he had been and everything he
was going to be all collided in this one
four month period so it was uh so it was
always the story and then it uh took a
long time to get it made and um every
time I thought of perhaps you know I
should really perhaps abandon it i' pick
up the screenplay again get to maybe
page two when I was hooked all over
again and also the specific modern essay
wit uh you know something I really
related to in a very strong way John
this is a pretty ambitious movie to make
independently can you tell us why it was
made outside the studio system and and
well I don't know if you've noticed but
the um the studi not really interested
in making original movies anymore I mean
for the most part um this would be a
movie that they would have made years
ago um this is a movie that needed to
get made and the only way we could get
it made was the way that we got it made
and and uh it's a tribute to Michael and
his tenaciousness and and all the actors
and everybody kind of working in a way
independently and which means like for
less money um and uh it you know a lot
less
money but like but you know it's um
stories like this have to get told and
you know we'll find one way or the other
way to do it and it it t it took a whole
lot I don't know if you noticed how many
producer credits are on the movie but
every single one of those people really
made a difference to help get this movie
made and without them we wouldn't be
sitting up here so I'm I'm sitting here
representing a whole lot of other people
who uh really helped get this movie made
and it was really like a labor of love
for everybody yeah um Eric I I read that
Michael's note to you was that he wanted
it to look like a Caravaggio painting
what do you do with that information um
you have a big glass of wine um yeah I
mean we sat down and we started talking
about Italian painting and and
particularly you know the Venetian
school Renaissance kind of early
Renaissance portraiture and um you know
it's it's an obvious connection you know
and and I then you know we went and and
Michael showed me a number of
photographs he had taken over the course
of prepping the movie and and I
immediately got completely seduced and
sucked into it because um you know he's
very thorough and um and I you know it's
it's to me that's what Italy looks like
you know that's just what Italy looks
like we leaned heavily into that idea
and hopefully passed it on Roberto we
were joking upstairs I asked you you
know how close were you to the action
and Michael said I I always like to make
him a little uncomfortable you've worked
together before how truly though how
close were you and what was the
experience like of of shooting these
cars those cars that are not too big
these not a lot of space and uh Michael
likes to use like this sker scope is
like a is a lens an additional lens that
you put in front of the real lens and
you can go really close to the actor I
feel what the pilot feel you know you go
fast and the noise and I think I'm
privileged to be there yeah Petro one of
my favorite scenes from an editing
standpoint is the Opera uh and we're
going back and forth between the Opera
and these flashbacks can you talk a
little bit about editing that scene
Michael wanted uh to have uh live
singing on stage he was really
particular that so you can't find a an
opera that we had and just find uh you
know people to uh you know use it as a
just a musical track as a playback to
sing so uh with the with the singers we
rehearsed we recorded it but we we
allowed them also to to have uh their
own recording with the music in in their
ear so when they're actually uh singing
uh on the closeup that's actually live
singing That's makes it very very
intimate uh and real the sound uh I love
the way uh uh Andy mixed it in terms of
I mean everybody is involved in the
Opera and the singing different
perspective but it is in their heart
you're really in it as close as you're
with the with the actors Andy one moment
where I really noticed the mix and
I I had a lot of fun with it is the
scene when they're in church and they're
all hitting the stopwatches listening to
the Maserati test and it seems like
there's a lot you had to calibrate there
you've got revving engines you've got
the dialogue you've got the watches can
you talk a little bit about that that
mix I mean we initially started with the
stopwatches for instance just the couple
that we saw and shot but it became very
obvious that the story the point of the
story was that they were all in The
workers's Mask but really they weren't
paying attention to what was going on
outside so we sort of doubled up and
tripled up and we ended up with about 40
or 50 different watches all ticking so
it filled the filled the atmosphere in
there and then the cutting backwards and
forwards I mean it was it was very
dynamic because of course the Maserati
had such a deep wonderful throbbing
sound to it and then of course the
beautiful um singing in the church and
then the watches so it was it kind of it
was a Melody but putting those three
elements together in itself was was like
a piece of music almost so did you find
by the end of this you know the
difference between the sound of a
Maserati and the sound of a
Ferrari uh yeah yes yes they are very
different and uh you know the beauty of
recording them afterwards um because as
as Michael explained you know there were
um modern engines for for shooting but
of course the film had been cut and um
so we could we could actually pick very
carefully the pieces we needed to record
because we had to get those cars from
people like Nick Mason's collection to
record but we could give very specific
instructions of what pieces we needed
the downshifts the accelerations the
cornering and we could drop them in
almost like ADR with an actor's voice
you know and uh that's how we put
together the uh the racing sounds yeah
what was the Ferrari family's
involvement it was it was essential I've
known Pio for about 20 years and uh
we're kind of the beneficiary of a lot
of trust and faith um I wanted him to
read the screenplay very early on he
didn't want to it's it's you can imagine
the sensitivity first of all he is as
characterized here there's an Italian
expression which means the son in
Waiting that's the son in the second
family waiting for maybe the father will
come home tonight maybe he won't so it's
a very anxious way to you know be raised
and um and portrays his mother and uh
his father's uh
relationships with Lara who was hostile
to Pier for the duration of her life she
used to go in the factory when pi went
to work in the factory when he was 19
and with a cane and slam it on the desk
and said where's the bastard this is the
uh so uh there's a lot of sensitivity
he's a very bright man he's a very
skilled engineer aircraft engineer and
he do well as being Vice chairman of um
Ferrari now but the um there was o Lena
lardy's niece who is very who everybody
said in the family is very similar to
Lena lardy and there was Lara's Doctor
Who revealed to us letters that no one
had ever seen before of um that Enzo
wrote to Lara late in life that are very
affectionate Romantics so he asked me
the first question what was so
interesting about this it's the
contradictory nature of all these people
the complexity of these characters which
is so fascinating the I find that um car
we build car in fiction we build
characters with contradictions we make
conflict happen it all resolves at the
end of the movie it doesn't happen that
way in life we carry our contradictions
to the grave and so the unresolved
nature the asymmetry of these people and
their relationships with each other
that's what really was uh was Central to
you know my commitment to it how much
were your drivers who we see on screen
how much were we watching actors how
much were we watching professional
drivers well you're watching both but
particularly Patrick Dempsey is a
professional driver he's had a couple of
Podium finishes at lemon and so he's
doing all his own driving as terui and
when it was when it was
realistic the guys drove themselves some
of it and then other times they were
professional drivers in some cases we I
have professional drivers be the actors
so Sterling Moss is a professional
driver um goty the actor playing
him
um I think one of uh my favorite scenes
is the one where Penelope crw is
confronting low is confronting um Enzo
and it's just a very emotionally
powerful scene I wonder if we could end
with you talking about what that was
like to shoot and I'm you know
interested in in well guess you know
that kind of drives to what Eric was
talking about about about the lighting
and the thing that we we admired about
col um about kagio we talked about it
quite a bit is that is that the light
was contrived to not be directed it's
it's light the room is lit and then it
and the actors move through it in the
paintings as well so it lands a slash of
light will land on a knee a hand and
pick up something else it's designed but
it doesn't look designed it looks like
it's it's you know the objective reality
put that light there and so when Ando
comes into the room he sits in the dark
and then when the when the uh when the
the fight between Enzo and Lara starts
taking place then he moves into the into
the light and
um very powerfully done well I thank you
so much for being here I thank you all
very much thank than you thank Youk you
so
[Applause]
much